on a le droit ici en france d'être très
direct par rapport aux états unis par
exemple si tu demandes à ton ami aux
états unis bah c'est comment mener ma
coupe de cheveux elle va te répondre
sûrement à it's amazing c'est vraiment
trop bien enfin j'adore alors qu'en
france si c'est un va pas battez amis
vont te le dire qu'est ce que tu as pris
enfin pourquoi t'as fait ça
cliché qg sur les français c'est que
tous les français sont vraiment vraiment
romantique et alors c'était c'était vrai
en fait parce que au japon on voit
jamais des couples qui s'embrassent on
la veut chi chi chi faire un gros câlin
s'est pas vraiment quelque chose qui est
bien vu au japon et mais en france c'est
normal les français y pense que sont le
nombril du monde qu'ils ont la meilleure
baguette le meilleur fromage le meilleur
vin le meilleur pain c'est vrai mais
après on amérique latine aussi on a de
très bons fromages prenantes encore que
chaque français que tous les français
sont très cultivé et il parle d' art
tout le temps et passe le saurez en
vendant dégustation de vin et passe de
lexique tuera et des armes devant a tout
le temps mais évidemment ce n'était pas
le cas les français sont très amis c'est
pour les haïtiens nous mêmes nous sommes
un petit peu plus relax les français
courent poids les portes ou les français
courent dans le métro les français qu'au
point de plus que ce que nous les
haïtiens vraiment être à l'heure n'est
pas la chose la plus importante pour
nous n'attendez pas aux crocs du chien y
en a partout il faut vraiment faire
attention à sa démarche à voir que ce
états unis on est un peu obligé de les
ramasser un peu et aussi pisser dans les
rues enfin jean j attendais pas du tout
à ça et du coup ça m'a beaucoup choqué
au début j'étais encore au top avec la
bise
une personne qui je ne connais pas qui
se posent des mois aux états unis on
possède la rogue
mais maintenant après deux ans ces
moments pour moi quand j'étais à paris
je me suis rendu compte
parce que il parlait surtout avec des
gros mots comme [ __ ] de bordel j'ai
été un peu choqué au japon le client est
toujours roi
le client a toujours raison donc c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une grande distance
entre un client et un vendeur mais en
france c'est plus naturel c'est plus
c'est plus humain parce que c'est pas le
vendeur et le client mais ces kits c'est
plus à un une personne qui est qu'ils
achètent et une personne qui vante donc
c'est pour ça que je me sens plus proche
avec les gens et je pense je me sens que
les vendeurs dans l dans les magasins
sont plus honnêtes
les français sont les seuls pendant une
phrase à la fin d'une phrase à dire et
aussi dans d'autres expressions comme
sifflé à la fin d'une phrase comme moi
j'arrive pas à le faire mais c'est très
drôle